I really want to address this story we
got this tweet from Alex Stein 99 prime
time he says it was just a joke dude
stool Presidente it's not that serious
let me play for you what David Portnoy
said and uh there's some Nuance to this
discussion but uh this is Alex Stein and
his wife's uh his wife's boyfriend uh
stormed into the Barstool Sports
headquarters here's what was said and
[ __ ] slap him in the face I don't
think that guy's been slapped yet so I'm
glad he got slapped
you you hear people be like oh they
should charge assault charge he should
have been shot if we had a gun effort a
ski mask in a deranged homeless man
trying to bargeon
yeah yeah right I think it's the actor
which is right craziest part Yeah Yeah
Bang Bang You're Dead it's all those all
those people who want that will be like
well if you come into my house I can
shoot you with my gun all right well if
you have two lunatics a guy wearing a
ski mask bang bang and hey that tub
alarm bang sorry you we told you to
leave you wouldn't they're all like you
leave no he didn't Danny was like
pushing him yeah
so where where are they based out of
what what city are they based on is this
New York or where are they at I think
New York City right I'm just going to
say first and foremost Dave you are
wrong because I'm sorry if you're in New
York City can someone fact check real
quick then you're wrong no if you're in
New York City you don't get to say
someone should be shot yeah
headquartered in NYC yeah if you're
doing but the show like that where they
actually don't record no I don't know if
you're doing a show in a city where you
constantly vote for and pay taxes and
support the stripping away of your right
to keep in bear arms you don't get to
say someone who entered a public office
should be shot yeah now that being said
we here in Western Maryland and West
Virginia with castle doctrine and active
threats against us and armed guards I
will say there's a big difference if
someone stormed through first of all you
got to enter a large property you have
to go past physical barricade saying do
not enter you are being warned you will
be shot then if somebody broke in here
I'd be like yeah you'd probably get shot
I don't want you to get shot I don't
think you should be you probably will be
because we're not going to try and
figure out your intention when you break
in but to stress Alex Stein was joking
I'm not a big fan of storming into the
podcast office you know causing a fight
and all that stuff in in a lot of
circumstances yeah
he'd get beaten up he'd get arrested all
that stuff but I just want to make sure
I can point out you can't say that when
you're in New York city so there's also
a difference in that how many times have
you been swatted how many times have
people actually yeah I mean is it really
that high yeah oh my God so it's like
obviously you know that that's a
different level I I don't think Dave
portnoy's getting swatted all that much
the libs kind of like him he plays this
Centrist character and so it just seems
a little over the top I get that Alex
Stein also is a little over the top but
I don't think blowing his brains out is
totally proportionate here you know I
mean the thing is they know who he is
they know like if Alex Stein shows up
you know you're being pranked by a
comedian with a comedian guy not saying
I agree with it but their office is also
open like I don't want to say it's open
to the public but you can just walk up
and enter it's like a building in a city
and so people are pointing out the fact
that he was able to walk up walk in the
building go through the door there's no
obstructions there's no signs or
anything well yeah guys you gotta get a
guard and put up a sign saying hey you
know private access only these things
won't happen yeah I think that him
saying it's a joke is a bit of a cop-out
I've been using the word cop out a
little bit too much lately but I think
it's not a joke jokes are words you tell
jokes you say them you if you're doing
something your actions that's something
that's a bit maybe it's a bit maybe it's
an act but it's not a joke can I I just
wanna I just want to point out too you
said he plays the Centrist but he's like
the the the the the
mirror verse version of centrism from
where we are like he's he's a Centrist
on all the worst things so like you know
he talks about being pro-choice but it's
just because if he knocks a girl up he
doesn't want to deal with it that's like
the worst reason to be pro-choice yeah
that was the argument he was making with
Andrew Tate
Andrew Tates are you going with him
against this what what kind of world are
we living in and when you live in New
York City and you pay taxes in New York
City you're paying for 15 plus minute uh
response times not for your right to
defend yourself so if you want to defend
yourself uh obviously you have a right
to do that uh you know the question's
Blurred here I mean when someone jumps
on your property you know what do you do
I mean the jurisdiction that he's in
doesn't allow him to do anything it's
not even his property I'm willing to bet
assuming that shell was in New York I
don't know where Alex is based on uh
well Alex Stein was in New York City
when he did this okay okay so these
buildings are multi-least right the the
so you're entering a building owned by
someone who's not Barstool Barstool
rents this space that's why he's able to
walk through the halls and go in the
elevator because it's a community-owned
thing now you come out to West Virginia
where we got 50 acres of our property
wrapped in a big old fence that says do
not enter we will defend ourselves with
lethal Force very very different
circumstance plus you know you're in New
York bro you can't have guns so yeah I
don't know what I I think he just wants
to be like he shouldn't have come in
here he should have come in here and I'm
like to a degree I would say you
shouldn't have but you're in a communal
building he's a prankster people can
just come and go as they please I agree
it's probably over the top isn't this
awesome but shooting someone and this is
this is a way that New Yorkers talk I
say this as a New Yorker myself you know
it's it's always the hypothetical in the
past uh you know what I would have done
you know what I would have done if I had
been there when I had seen it all I
would have done it so bad when it's just
be this he's not gonna he would have sat
there like everybody else of course of
course I think Alex's taunting Dave he's
been taunting him for like a month and a
half and Dave finally I mean he went
into his his office and made a loud
noise and smell I'm sure uh no not that
Alex smells bad but you're letting your
smell out you know your pheromones bro
uh and Dave really took the bait but him
saying that you should have been shot
Alex is a lot of people are going to
hear that and a lot of people are going
to think okay if a guy comes into my
office maybe I should be shooting them
so that's a very bad bad thing this is
why you do not kill Joker on people no
no look you just can't New York City
liberal guy yeah saying like I should
have no you wouldn't you'd vote to ban
guns come on you know what's weird to me
though about this is some conservatives
really like Dave Portnoy and I can you
know he he's not exactly my flavor of
conservatism but where did the Bad Blood
start with Stein and Portnoy about a
month and a half ago on Twitter I think
uh Alex it was real minor to be like
Dave you smell I don't know what were
the dumb tweets I wish Alex was here to
tell us I don't know no it started with
something specific that really yeah but
it was like a low-key it wasn't but Alex
really was like I like this I want the
attention I want to make a big deal out
of it it's good for me and Dave publicly
I think was Alex's mindset no but but
look Alex Stein is a very very smart guy
yeah I'm on the show a couple times he's
wild he's obnoxious but he is quick yeah
like he comes up with these one-liners
and these jokes I'm like the dude knows
what he's doing and what he's talking
about he's got a plan yeah the plan may
be crazy it may be a bit joker-ish but
Stein's a smart guy and he was like Dave
I was joking like earlier on a week ago
he's like damn I'm joking around come on
let's have fun and but Dave was already
too he was angry at that point and I
haven't seen Dave cool down yet so what
was it Chrissy Mayer said they waltered
him because your receptionist is dumb
and buzzed them in is that what happened
because if that's what happened then
Dave sorry you've lost every like yeah
you know every argument isn't there also
a difference between if a guy busts in
to my home at night or something then
yeah if I can get a gun I'll start
blasting away but if a guy comes into my
office well I'll just take my producer
Ben Davis and hold him right in front of
me and so you know he can take all the
bullets or anything but I'm going to go
a little bit when the pandemic was was
heating up there was a viral video out
of I think it was Los Angeles County or
something where a guy a gun A gun shop
owner said stop getting mad at me that I
can't sell you guns you voted for this
you voted for the wait periods you voted
for permitting you cannot buy guns it's
your fault people were struck up to gun
shops being like I'd like to buy a gun
he'd be like okay fill this form out
come back in a week and then go what I
need a gun now and I'm like yeah well
you voted for it or didn't vote at all
so to have these New York City liberals
in a state that is a duty to retreat I'm
assuming New York is that way New Jersey
is that way in New Jersey if someone
breaks in your house you have to flee
your own home
to where to Florida Tennessee they
called it right exactly they call it
partial castle doctrine I talked to a
lawyer about it because someone tried
breaking in and he was like if there is
an if someone breaks in your house and
there is any way you can escape you have
to and I'm like window yep door yep jump
off the balcony and he's like within
reason obviously but like if you're in
your house and someone goes to the front
door you got to go out the back and I'm
like go where go Dunkin Donuts and then
call the cops and then I'm just like and
if there are people trapped inside
they're like well you know it's it's
it's interesting but depends on what
they're going to argue and what I was
told is that the prosecutors in Jersey
of course they will argue you did wrong
no matter what you did so that's why I
like West Virginia West Virginia someone
breaks in your house you defend yourself
the cops say shouldn't have come into
your house you get in trouble in New
York City for having pepper spray yeah
yeah it's a duty to retreat I mean I
grew up in New York City too it is yeah
it's not only your retreat it's a
retreat uh pull your pants down bend
over and yes just take it because what
else are you going to do uh other than
of course be a helpless victim as
criminals there obviously have guns
obviously they have ways of getting guns
with the Glock switches and everything
but you no you're not you're not trusted
enough to do that is it because
vigilante justice was out of control or
something
like why did they make it why can't you
just stop someone from coming into your
house in New York I don't know it's a
good question yeah well because when
cops kick your door in they don't want
to be worried about it the cops don't
want to fear that if they serve a bunk
warrant or enter the wrong house they're
gonna get a shock reprisal
because criminals are going to have guns
anyway yeah didn't Indiana pass a law
saying that if a cop wrongly enters your
home you could legally defend yourself I
think Ohio did too I think it was
Indiana yeah yeah I I saw Michael malice
tweeting about this celebrating it
really he was very Catalyst I'm gonna
look it up right now that's amazing
because you know me and Malice are both
anarchists just so you understand where
we're coming from yeah that could
explain the debate we're having which is
which is great and awesome well I'll
tell you too I was saying this uh to
malice I was saying this to some of my
more kind of iron Randy friends because
I don't I don't like Iran Rand I went
through a phase when I was a teenager
really
um I I hate Iran but the more that I
live through covid and post covid the
more that I see I don't know I'm gonna
wind up an anarchist somehow I'm gonna
wind up a Trad Anarchist I think because
you know now this is why it's also
Dave's fault if you are still conducting
business in New York or L.A
uh it's that's your fault you had plenty
of time to get out you get out like
there's no reason to stay there okay
West Virginia forcing your will onto
other people isn't cool being a statist
and authoritarian is not cool yeah
except for sometimes yeah
if I keep pooping in your water supply
see this is this is this is where I
differ with also you know the our the
anarchists and libertarian Friends of
the show is that
um I I look at jurisdiction right I've
had the Libertarians argue no borders
borders are imaginary anarchists borders
are imaginary and I was like how do you
protect your family if you don't set a
perimeter to where you're allowed to
live peacefully like jurisdiction is
actually setting a limitation on
yourself I actually feel that arguing
for no borders is an extension of your
authority over others right when the
United States says this is our Southern
border we're not going to go over there
well we do anyway but the idea is this
is my property line I'm not going to go
over by you this is where I'm gonna do
my thing please leave me alone if we
said borders don't matter you're
basically saying at any point I can go
over by you and do what I need to do and
also that's just an expression of the
false anthropology at the heart of
anarchism and libertarianism you guys
are straw Manning this I just want to
say for the record here and uh it's far
more complicated because if we could get
into details like welfare and Welfare
incentivizing people to move over we
could talk about the weaponization of
immigration and I think the mises caucus
especially under uh Dave Smith has been
addressing this issue in a very smart
and correct way addressing this
immigration issue in uh in a more
correct way saying hey as as long as we
have the welfare state we shouldn't have
open immigration
you if you got rid of the welfare state
then borders should be erased or
something I mean well it depends it's a
complicated argument and there's many
different factors that are multifaceted
here to me anarchism it's not an all-end
solution to everything it's never going
to be perfect but I think as Humanity we
should always be striving for personal
responsibility and for personal freedom
and liberty and and I agree to a great
extent my concern is
the Communist Party of China exists
they've exerted authoritarian control
over their people to the extent where
they're welding them into their homes we
can be the anarchists of free trade and
all that and when the Chinese Communist
Party comes knocking and says we'd like
to purchase some land and free trade and
we say sounds good to us then before we
know it they own 40 of the Farmland in
the west coast and then all of a sudden
they're using that against us cutting
off supply lines we're being attacked
from within which means I'd love for
there with you look at the United States
and and Ron Paul made a great point that
I love where he said in the US you can
be a socialist go buy land go go set up
your little socialist commune why do you
want to force everyone else to do that
we set the boundaries we set the rules
we agree on those rules and then we can
live in peace and Harmony we're also
discussing these things as though
they're opposites when they're communism
and anarchism when in fact they're two
sides of the same coin because they
partake of the same false anthropology
which says that the fundamental
political institution is the individual
which is not true and has never been
true the fundamental political unit is
the family and so people are not born as
the enlightenment of post-enlightenment
rationalists would have you believe as
individuals with a bunch of Rights and
entitlements but primarily though we do
have rights but we are born not as these
atoms floating through space but into
families with duties and obligations and
and so your love of your state and your
love of your country is an extension of
that filial piety because you have an
obligation to to respect your father and
mother I think centralization is is a
big problem throughout human history I
think but that's a decentralization uh
essentially this this is what kind of
boils down but again we're getting into
larger ideology but what's the balance
of the two you can't have
authoritarianism or Pure Energy you
can't have pure either they're too
extreme right now I think right now it's
more it's more than fair to say that we
are more centralized than ever and we
need more detention and this is what the
philosophy of anarchism is pushing
because right now I think it's fair to
say that too many people uh in the
central government have too much power
over everyone else and we need to limit
that and this is where we agree and I
think when you look at the political
compass the least populated portion of
it is the center left liberal it's
either far left moderate authoritarian
to very authoritarian and then you have
moderate conservative to like
libertarian right and then you actually
I would argue have more authoritarian
right-wingers than you actually have
center-left liberal libertarian types it
just doesn't exist and the center left
lib but most people who claim B are
literally not most people claim to be
our authoritarian left want speech
policing to an extreme I was just told
that that's what I was when I took the
test this is the point and I'll get into
the next Story the point is
if you are on the libertarian spectrum
of the political Compass you still have
a degree of authority that you expect to
exist unless you're all the way on the
bottom at Anarchy all right listen we
talked about this before on a local
small level I you know I forgot who said
this someone more smarter than me said
this on a local family level you should
be Communists and then on a community
level you should be socialists and then
on a state level you should move away
further from centralization and call for
more decentralization and I agree the
family unit I think is one of the most
important units but I think we also have
to respect the the the the strongest
minority of them all and that's the
individual uh and you could still do
that while of course prioritizing
families communities and neighborhoods
and individuals coming together to work
together without any kind of mafioso
central control or government bureaucrat
coming in and getting a cut of the money
no but the trads love subsidiarity I
mean that's a principle of uh well put
forward by Thomas Aquinas and by
conservatives since time immemorial I
think the place we're getting confused
is we're pretending that
individualism you know the anarchists
and the Communists are opposites when
they both accept the same fundamental
premise which I think is a wrong premise
which is that the individual is the
primary unit of society and so the
anarchists say it's the individual and
it has to remain that way and the
Communists say it's the individual and
that's why we've got to lump them all
together but it's the conservatives who
are offering the only genuine
alternative which says no it's actually
not about this individualism it doesn't
just come down to the individual it
comes down to something that is that is
more institutional and actually
fundamental to your Humanity which is
family and community and tradition and
not just the use of your individual
unfettered reason to come up with some
cockamami idea it's why I think Karl
Marx if you were alive today would be in
the tea party or something
absolutely disagree with that and well
it's total Essence and when we look at
essentially what is boiling Down to What
a lot of these larger parties and ideas
especially when it comes to
conservatives and what they're doing
they're essentially just kind of the
Liberals 10 years from now when you look
at the policies when you look at them
deciding to use force and government
against other individuals to impose
their ideas I think at the end of the
day this is the key Central role when uh
anarchists and Libertarians don't want a
central figure don't want someone
telling them what to do and I think this
notion of back and forth the government
is good they're going to tell us what to
do right do they have the ultimate
decision making and what is good and bad
I think that pendulum is when it swings
back and forth between the left and
right is only bringing on more
government more authoritative
authoritarianism and I think we need a
lot less but Luke do you not see the
irony of of you know lamenting that the
wicked conservative authoritarians want
to impose their views and use this power
of the state on you when what you are
advocating is you're saying what we need
to do Michael is we need to get rid of
our political order in the United States
we need to get rid of tradition we need
to get rid of no orders
well what you are suggesting is a
radical upending of our political order
at the very least
Utopia
it's not fair to put words in my mouth
I strongly believe in in families I
think they should be prioritized and I
think individuals should treat families
in a kind of communistic way on the
individual basis without any kind of
force or government intervening in that
this is why I'm a huge proponent of
homeschooling this is why I'm a huge
proponent of moving away uh from
depending on government for daily life
what if the family of responsibility
what if the families abuse kids uh
that's a horrible situation that needs
to be mitigated by the government
um that's a very hard decision that's
that's that's one example that is very
hard to deal with and again
you're making you're making this very
Niche kind of argument but I could say
what about the government raping small
children
let's keep the conversation in line and
not go yeah far off uh what if the
government determines that not
vaccinating your kids
is is abuse right so the the challenges
that we have and that that that point
right there is why I say morality is not
uh logical morality is amorphous it's
it's an analog it's not digital we say
something like you shouldn't be allowed
to abuse your kids if a guy is beating
his child we should intervene and stop
that yeah and then someone else says
you're right and if you're not giving
the kid the appropriate medical
treatment for their disease that's abuse
and then you ask the question
which medical treatment are we talking
about are we talking about a vegan mom
who's not giving her son any meat yeah
and and because she's determined what's
right for her kids and then we intervene
or are we talking about say a gender
transition program where the government
says it's abuse if you don't give it to
him there's not a one for one answer the
only and I I agree with that of course
the only point I'm trying to make is
that I find libertarianism and anarchism
to be extremely authoritarian in as much
as they seek to impose a political order
on me that I think is absurd and that I
don't want I don't want to live in a
political order in which I in a
self-government cannot through my
representatives and through the police
force take a child out of an abusive
home a Libertarian or an anarchist might
prefer that but that's not what I want
so I find it very authoritarian but you
would rather have a government and
support a government and pay taxes to a
government that's running international
trafficking or organizations
if he's making an argument saying I
support you know but I can make the same
argument there no I never said here's
the idea the ideal is if if a guy
punches a kid in the face we protect
that kid and get it away from that
person if a guy's beating his wife we
get his wife out of there but then
there's a simple challenge the law says
you shall not cause physical harm to
your children or your spouse be it male
or female and then we say that's a fine
law you cannot physically harm and then
someone goes this woman was giving her
kid an all soy diet with no protein and
he's sickly anemic and about to die we
sort of have is do we intervene in that
regard but the mother says I know what's
right for my kid then we say okay you're
right she's abusing the kid then someone
says oh but there the government Dr
fauci says this vaccine is has to be for
kids and the parent won't do it should
the government then intervene it's the
same law right and so it would
interpreted in different scenarios
traditionally the American response to
this is that we have a self-government
and to your point Luke it very often it
does not appear that we actually have a
self-government increasingly but
notionally that's the idea at least and
So within this self-government we have
the right as Citizens to come to answers
on the questions and say you know the
all soy diet that is abusive you're not
allowed to do that the vaccine no we're
not going to make you vaccinate your
kids and that's particular but that does
mean that we have the right to impose
our views of the world on others that is
the premise and prerequisite of
self-government if you do not do that
then well you'll have to impose some
other political order which will get you
right back to the same time let me ask
you Luke uh if a kid had strep throat
bacterial and the doctor said we're
gonna I don't know what the actual
treatment is amoxicillin do they still
do much yeah
and the mother says no I don't want any
of that weird stuff we're going to give
him tree bark do you think the
government should intervene or just let
the Kid die there's there's a lot of
variables in that particular situation
so again hypotheticals are not my
favorite I don't think it's fair to even
issue a lot of those kind of houses
I don't try and patter your way out I'm
not patterning my way I'm addressing the
situation I don't I don't think it's a
fair I don't think it's a fair question
now obviously how's it not a fair
question a kid has a very simply curable
bacterial infection and the mom doesn't
want to give him medicine should the
government intervene
um
at this instant in this current
situation uh the government will
intervene but nobody should should the
internet I don't have all the answers
this is the challenge when I start
thinking about how yes I want to be much
more libertarian I don't like vaccine
mandates and when we say something like
look I've had uh when I was a kid you
know strep throat or whatever and they
gave me that pink stuff that tasted
really really great it was like
strawberry flavored amoxicillin or
something and it cures you we know
antibiotics cure diseases shout out to
fungus shout out to fungus so if I see a
parent who's like I'm gonna rub crystals
on my kid I'm like well look I don't
like the idea that the government can
come in and tell a parent how to raise
their kid that's a big problem but
there's also
man what do you do we know that that
anti antibiotics can cure certain
diseases
how do we navigate this when Dr fauci
says You must do this for your kid right
even if it's like you know like and
we're in phase three trials it's only
been a couple years at that point you're
like I object
but it's this at the core the Nuance of
the situation is different but it's the
same thing do I accept the government
can intervene when a person defies the
net the the science
man now I'm like I'm watching a kid die
a strep throat when I know he could save
his life because I don't want someone to
be forced to inject their kid over here
I don't have the answer well there's
also one that there's a difference
between amoxicillin and the fauciology
you know we have a lot more long-term
data on one of those than the other but
but also to your point can the
government do this there is an
historical matter here which you've
which you've pointed out Luke which is
that
throughout all of human history in every
single Society in every single place on
planet Earth the the government by which
we mean people having power within
political communities do impose those
things every single place occasionally
anarchists will say you know in 8th
Century Iceland or something but you
know okay fine but every everywhere yeah
right right if you look at government
interventions I mean again anarchism
doesn't have all the solutions doesn't
have all the answers and I do believe uh
children should always be protected
obviously that should be a common no no
no hold on hold on but hold up I've got
to address the point okay okay but this
is the larger point that I wanted to
make here I'm not finished here I'm
laying down the groundwork for this
point but you don't agree with that you
don't think kids should always be
protected it depends on the
circumstances and situations I don't
want to be the central controller
deciding a lot of these things a lot of
these things will be decided by
individuals or communities or families
and neighborhoods that will decide for
themselves what is right and I believe
at the end of the day that is a better
thing that will happen rather than a
government coming in and taking a kid
and putting them into C plus
look at how horrible our CPS system is
look at how many kids get hurt inside of
the CPS I have a question so so all I'm
saying is at the end of the day I don't
have all the answers and solutions here
no one does obviously there's flaws in
every single political argument and
political ideology yes so obviously but
at the end of the day individuals should
decide for themselves not Central
controllers so let me ask a simple
question
two circumstances
government says we will not intervene in
what the family decides to do with their
child the family then decides they will
sterilize and castrate their kid and
give them hormones
second scenario you mean what they're
doing right now with family protection
second scenario family says we will not
give this kid hormone therapy and
surgery and the government does
intervene right which one's the right or
wrong one do we say the government
should not intervene in the parents
decision as they decide to give their
kid what they deem best a sex change or
do we stop the government from forcing
the sex change because the child wants
it and the state taking responsibility
away from yourself taking decisions away
from the family from the community is to
me a recipe
that's my main argument do you think not
some emotional argument about kicking a
baby
if a mother and father publicly announce
that their child of 12 wants to be
castrated and injected with hormones
should we just say that's your choice as
a parent
um I I think that should be pushed back
against it in many different ways that's
a horrible decision decision that's
going to hurt the child and I think they
should there should at least be informed
consent and some Community involvement
How can there be participation for the
kid well kids should always be protected
this is where I disagree with a lot of
the bigger kind of libertarian and
Anarchist ideas especially when they say
we got to sell heroin to kids obviously
that's the wrong idea obviously that's
something that that I I stand against
and I made clear many times before on
this particular show but when it comes
to these important decision making
decisions at the end of the day I do
believe and I have a lot more faith in a
family in a community in the
neighborhood and in individuals rather
than the big government that we have now
that uses our tax dollars in horrible
ways and hurts way more people than the
larger ideologies of anarchism which I
believe at the end of the day would lead
to less harm reduction I just wanted to
say that that scenario I gave of the
parents are doing it and the government
doesn't intervene and the parents don't
want it the government does intervene is
exemplifies my point about how laws are
based on amorphous morals analog morals
like
in which circumstance do we decide the
government is or isn't right well and
also the the interpretation of
intervention here is I think problematic
because the the government by which and
Luke you keep conflating these things
where you say well no I don't like the
government I just like Community well
the government is the expression of the
political Community especially in a
notionally self-governing especially now
what's happening with the elections
especially now with the way that they're
running things
certain elections are an expression but
we're falling maybe not Maricopa County
yeah especially now how much debt they
put us in especially now I mean the
national debt is an expression of the
political community of making choices
absolutely this is how I I drift more
away from anarchism and libertarianism I
recognize sometimes we want the
government to intervene and sometimes we
don't
and it's it there's no way to define it
other than a judgment it just seems like
a person it seems to me the government
the government is always intervening in
the sense that we live in a society we
live in a political community in order
to live together in a society we come up
with rules and norms and institutions to
mediate the people in that Society the
families and the but why can't
communities do that why do you need a
government to do that that is what a
government is this is the expression of
a pla the the expression enforcement I
think that's been highly bastardized and
highly incorrect with the way the
government is now you're talking about
federal government and large government
right you're advocating for smaller
localized government I'm talking what
essentially is a mafia coming in there
and saying I will impose my will on you
because I know what's best for you I'm
against those ideas but but when we're
talking about let's just use the term
political Community then because which I
think is actually more precise within a
political Community
there is always a way that people are
living and being raised so for instance
if the mode of Education within the
political Community says that men and
women are different and Men Can't become
women and women can't become men then I
guess you're not going to have these
kids getting castrated and injected with
with uh poison but is that the
government intervening I just think this
idea that the government is active or
passive is no the government just is the
political Community just is and we're
always constantly living in a state of
standards and norms and so the question
is not this procedural question is will
the government do something or not the
question is just what is the government
doing thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time